House Speaker Nancy Pelosi they're
announcing the names of the seven
impeachment managers basically they'd
but essentially the prosecutors at the
president Trump's Senate impeachment
trial who include as the lead manager
Adam Schiff and House Chairman Jerry
Nadler and her keen Jeffrey this is
about the Constitution of the United
States said speaker Pelosi the emphasis
here is on litigators let's go live now
to Capitol Hill and Al Jazeera's Heidi
Joe Castro once again what are we to
make of that Heidi
hadrian the the first two names at
Pelosi announced as the lead manager and
the second manager there's no surprise
as you mentioned it's Nadler and Schiff
who are the chairman of the two House
committees who led up the inquiry of
this of the impeachment of President
Donald Trump now the five other managers
it's an interesting selection speaker
Pelosi said they were chosen because
they are litigators they can get the job
done as prosecutors and presenting this
case this legal case to have the
president convicted in the hopes of
Democrats to be removed from office
however there's also a couple other
statements that can be argued that she's
making here we're seeing that three of
these five other impeachment managers
come from the Progressive Caucus showing
that Democrats have come together on
this impeachment effort that they are
politically united in this effort we're
also seeing that three of those five
remaining and Peter managers are
non-white we have two African Americans
we have a Latina congresswoman really an
effort also of the Democratic leadership
in in preparing for this upcoming trial
that will be broadcast all over American
television screens in helping Democrats
try to make their argument to voters
that the prosecution of this case case
is an extension of the voice of the
American people and in all their
diversity so that argument can be made
as well and of course all of this is in
keeping in mind exactly what images will
last and well and what will be
remembered as part of this trial and of
course the show if so to speak begins
this very day once these impeachment
managers are confirmed in a resolution
vote before the full house later today
we will see them holding the articles of
impeachment in envelopes and parading
through the steps of Congress from one
side of the US Capitol where the House
of Representatives needs to the other
side where this Senate has its chambers
and that will be a very ceremonial
affair which will kick off then the next
phase of this impeachment idea many
thanks indeed how did your caster on
Capitol Hill let's go live now to the
White House our White House
correspondent Kimberly how could is with
us Kimberly I was gonna start by saying
that the president has been
uncharacteristically quiet on Twitter
this morning and then four minutes ago
up it pops do you want me to read it or
shall I do you want to read it rather or
shall I do it you can have the artists
here we go again he says another con job
by the do-nothing Democrats all of this
work was supposed to be done by the
house not the Senate yeah so here's what
I make about all out of all of this as I
listen to Nancy Pelosi as we've now got
this tweet from the US president what
we've seen here is the battle that has
been going on in percolating for about
four weeks now and that is how to shape
the Senate trial and we heard there from
the Democrats as they presented their
case essentially giving it kind of the
last-ditch effort to say we want to hear
from witnesses pointing to the
Republicans saying that they're trying
to engage in a cover-up and what we need
is for this information to come out the
question became how is the president
when this trial happens how is he going
to try and exert his influence because
we certainly saw it in the house not
only did we see him blocking impeachment
testimony but we also saw him as
witnesses were testifying tweeting in
real-time some would allege it was
witness intimidation well it appears the
president is planning as we saw this
coming down and the president tweeting
that he's planning to weigh in on this
once again and that is what Republicans
are having this very difficult sort of
balancing act in all this in the Senate
to try and figure out they need to look
objective like they're having a fair
trial they need to potentially call
these witnesses Democrats argue but
Democrats are also playing a dangerous
game because you heard they're in some
of the questioning if Democrats get
their witnesses they want to hear from
some key members of the Trump
administration like you know protential
II the Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
the national security adviser former
John Bolton all very damaging for the
president but Republicans could call
hunter Biden the son of former
President Joe Biden questions could
surface about why he was sitting on a
board of an energy company when the
former vice president was overseeing
Ukraine policy so in the midst of all of
this were seeing this back and forth I
think it's safe to assume from the
president's tweet that he is in a way
weighing in early and plans to do so
throughout this trial that as howdy Joe
Castro reported is set to really kick
off early next week
al-jazeera's White House correspondent
Kimberly Hellcat there live in
Washington Kimberly many thanks Bruce
Fein is a former United States associate
Deputy Attorney General he helped draft
the article of impeachment against
President Bill Clinton and joins us now
live from Washington
so Bruce we now know there will be seven
impeachment managers led by House
Chairman Adam Schiff the emphasis House
Speaker Pelosi said is on litigators I
think that's a misplaced emphasis in my
view the narrative is quite clear to
anyone who's not totally a blind to what
everyone knows the transactional
politics of mr. Trump what he did with
regard to withholding the military aid
to Ukraine in exchange for soliciting
some aid by the president of Ukraine to
help his 2020 campaign by opening a
public investigation of hunter Biden and
his company is quite clear you don't
need litigators to prove that water runs
downhill
what is absent is those who have our
statesmen who have a true mastery of the
Constitution
remember the key words here are treason
bribery and other high crimes and
misdemeanors
the standard for it's just not any
constitutional violation like who in the
well one for example would be Jamie
Raskin he's the chairman of the
subcommittee of the Constitution and he
teaches constitutional law I happen to
know Jamie but he is far superior to
others in grasping the nature of
impeachable offenses I don't I agree
that there's not a whole surplus of
those who command the Constitution
because we've become a constitutional
illiterate Society but at least there
ought to be an attempt to seek to point
people like the Jamie raskins because
without this larger understanding of
what the nature of a high crime and
misdemeanor is people will say well it's
Ukraine
so what if we didn't give the money to
Ukraine it'd probably be squandered
anyway and it's not a danger to our
national security you need to understand
why the precedent is quite dangerous
here the other element that also struck
me is as follows bribery is clearly a
justification for impeachment and
earlier on in the investigation miss
Pelosi herself said there was a
solicitation of bribery here namely
President Trump
solicited something of value to himself
personally assistance in the 2020
campaign to influence his official act
in releasing military aid to Ukraine why
wasn't that charged they have this vague
argument of what's abuse of power well
abuse of power is nowhere in the
Constitution itself so it much the
tracks I think from the ability to
strike or strike the the the winning
blow to say you can't dispute that
bribery is a hike as is an impeachable
offense but they walked away from that
in my view it's because Nancy Pelosi had
her tactics dictated by the so-called
moderate Democrats who fear they could
lose the 2020 reelection campaign
because they are in so-called Trump
districts Bruce it's always good to talk
to you many thanks indeed for being with
us Bruce Fein there in Washington